So welcome back to human emotion.
Um,
today we're gonna continue our
discussion about this, Nate,
the nature of these emotions that
are so intimately part of ourselves.
So this is the family of
self conscious emotions.
And we're going to wrap up our discussion
about this family of self conscious
emotions by focusing
today on guilt and shame.
So some of our most perhaps
socially painful emotions.
We're going to explore why we have them
in the first place and what sort of
social good they actually serve for us.
So we've talked about four different
self conscious emotions so far,
pride, embarrassment, and we've
touched on shame and guilt.
But today what we're going to do is really
delve deeper into the nature of shame
and guilt, which we know are in this
broad family of self conscious emotions.
People have also called
them moral emotions.
And what seems to be unique about
shame and guilt is that they're also
associated with some sort of wrongdoing.
So what is it that makes shame and guilt
what they are that makes them unique
and that makes them part of this
family of self conscious emotions.
So one of the things about shame and guilt
is that they are largely and uniquely
human emotions,
right?
They are also something that are not,
that they don't emerge at birth.
We don't have them from a very young age,
but they seem to sort of take on,
you know, a very powerful role in our
life a bit later in our development.
Um, and importantly, um,
I've talked about them as being referred
all also as moral emotions in so far as
even though there are
associated with wrongdoing,
they also serve this function that's
really focused on helping us, you know,
to reign in or inhibit some
of our more aggressive,
harmful and perhaps socially
undesirable behaviors.
So they serve this function to help
us reign in some of our more uh,
undesirable behavioral tendencies.
Now what's interesting too,
I think about shame and guilt is
that you've heard these words before.
We've all heard them and in fact we use
them in lay conversation all the time.
However we use them interchangeably,
right?
We sort of refer to feeling ashamed
or guilty as one in the same thing.
And not only do sort of our everyday
friends, colleagues, you know,
partners use these words interchangeably,
but it seems that even psychologists who
work with their clients in a clinical
context seem to use some of these words
there as well. So we see, for example,
here,
this is the Dsm or the diagnostic and
statistical manual of mental disorders.
We also see here if you peek into the
Dsm here and this is the criteria for
major depressive disorder,
that what we see here is one of the core
associated symptoms or features that I
highlighted in blue here.
Our feelings of worthlessness or guilt.
So not only is this something that we
all know intimately in our lives that we
use common,
the conversation,
but it's even part of the very criteria
that psychologists and psychiatrists use
to, um, sort of dispense
diagnoses, you know,
to sort of determine whether or not
someone meets criteria for something as
severe and chronic as depression.
So guilt and shame play a
pretty big role in our life.
And yet in some ways we have a hard
time distinguishing which is which.
So when is it shame and when
is someone feeling guilty?
So I want to show you an example from a
recent sort of pop culture reference and
have you decide.
So what I'm going to do is show you a
video of tiger woods where he sort of
broadcast his apology to the
world for all of his infidelities.
You know that he committed
against his wife.
And I want you to watch closely and decide
for yourself whether or not you think
what he's experiencing is shame,
guilt,
or perhaps both.
So take a moment to watch
this and see what you think
every one of you has good
reason to be critical of me.
I want to say to each of
you simply and directly,
I am deeply sorry for my irresponsible
and selfish behavior I engaged in.
I know people want to find out how I
could be so selfish and so foolish.
People want to know how I could have
done these things to my wife feeling
and to my children.
And while I have always
tried to be a private person,
there are some things I want to say.
Elan and I have started the process
of discussing the damage caused by my
behavior.
As Ellen pointed out to me,
my real apology to her will
not come in the form of words.
It will come from my behavior over time.
We have a lot to discuss and a,
however,
what we say to each other will
remain between the two of us.
I am also aware of the pain
my behavior has caused.
For those of you in this room,
I have let you down.
I let down my fans
socio watch this video. What do you
think? Is this shame or is the skills,
and I want you to keep this question in
your mind as we now go into the rest of
our lecture today and
define what is shame,
what is guilt and in what ways do they
overlap and show similarity and in what
ways are they fundamentally
different emotions all together.
And then we'll return at the end
to our beloved. Um, you know,
celebrity tiger woods and ask whether
or not he felt shame or guilt.
So we're going to start today
by first talking about guilt.
This will be followed by shame and then
we'll compare and contrast guilt and
shame followed by our takeaway
questions and expert interview.
So let's start with guilt.
What is it really?
So I want you to now think about again,
your own experience or
a time in your life.
You remember feeling
really guilty to again,
take out a pen and piece of paper and
I want you to write down what was the
circumstance that led you to feel guilty.
I also want you to write down what
thoughts were going through your mind when
you were feeling guilty. What were you
thinking about? Was it about yourself,
about the behavior, about other people's
perceptions? What were you thinking?
And then finally,
what do you think the social outcome or
purpose of feeling guilty was in that
circumstance?
Did it motivate you to do any particular
behavior or to engage with other people
in one way or another? So pause the
video, take a few moments to do this.
And then when you return, we'll go
through what researchers have described,
some of the core features of what makes
guilt feel so bad and what makes people
feel so guilty.
And really what good does it serve?
So we touched on the characteristics of
guilt in our last couple of lectures.
And just as a sort of recap,
guilt is really triggered by you having
this negative evaluation about yourself.
So you're thinking something
I'm really sort of, um,
powerful about, I'm sorry Nigga
value valuation of your action.
So this is about some behavior that you
performed and you feel bad about it.
So you might say like,
I can't believe I stole that thing.
So you reflect on a behavior you did
and you evaluate it in a negative light.
This leads you to have negative emotions
towards the target and to have some
sort of, um, mobilization or,
or readiness to address the problem,
right?
Caused by your behavior that you
negatively evaluate. So as a consequence,
you feel motivated to address the problem.
Maybe it's returning the stolen item,
for example.
Okay,
now let's talk again about shame then.
So again,
what I want you to do, and I think
this is really important to do this,
to engage in these exercises because
what I'm going to have you do is once you
sort of compare,
write down your own guilt experience,
and now engage in your own
thought exercise about shame.
What I want you to do later is you're
going to put them side by side and compare
them.
So please pause for a moment.
Take out a piece of paper and think
about a separate time in your life,
not the same as what you thought
about earlier with respect to guilt.
Think about a tiny felt very ashamed.
Now again,
I want you to think about describing the
circumstance that led you to feel this
way.
What were the thoughts going through your
mind and what were some of the social
purposes or outcomes as a
result of feeling this way?
What were you inclined to do?
How did you behave around others?
Did you engage with others or did you
sort of retreat into your own space?
So please take a moment to do this cause
I assure you that this will be really
important when you take your own
personal life experiences. Um,
as a way to really understand the
complex nature of these negative socially
painful self conscious emotions.
So once you've done that,
you can hit play and we'll go back
through some of the features of shame.
So again,
as a reminder,
some of the characteristics of shame
that we talked about earlier are that
involves a negative evaluation
of yourself as a whole.
So it's in contrast with guilt,
which was about a very local specific
behavior here with shame as a whole.
You're seeing yourself in this negative
light. So instead of I stole that object,
it's,
I'm a thief.
And the behavior that you typically show
here again is to sort of have a sense
of smallness and sort of
inconspicuousness around others.
So hunched over posture, try to
retreat or high premier social groups.
So really your behavior's really mobilized
towards hiding and being undetected
by others.
And as a consequence,
you're very unlikely to
take a corrective action.
You're just wanting to
retreat in the whole,
feel bad about yourself as a whole and
not necessarily do anything to remedy the
situation as you would in the
case of guilt, for example. Um,
something interesting about shame is
that we see some really fascinating cross
cultural differences. So here
what we're, if you're look here,
this is contrasting individualistic
cultures on the left.
So you can think of the United
States is a prime example with more
collectivistic cultures.
Um, uh, on the right here.
So individuals that cultures are really
sort of emphasizing the sense of me or I
and collectivistic cultures are
more about your inner dependence and
connectedness to others.
So it's more about this sense of us.
Now on the left, we know the
individuals to cultures. Um, you know,
one self identity is really separate
from other people and that you sort of
follow your own individualized
or personalized standards
of norms for what are
sort of socially acceptable
behaviors or behaviors that you,
yourself think are appropriate.
By contrast here on the right
in collectivistic cultures,
the sense of one sense of self identity
cannot be separated from other people.
Um, yourself and sense of connection to
others are sort of part and parcel of the
same phenomena or sort of how
you think about who you are.
Not surprisingly as a result,
your standard of norms for what are
acceptable or appropriate behaviors are
really interpersonal.
So they're really about linking you to
other people or between other people.
So again,
what we're seeing is a sense of self and
individualistic cultures versus a sense
of otherness in collectivistic cultures.
So then when we think
about the role of shame,
what we see here is that we really see
it play out more in these collectivistic
cultures on the right and it plays less
of a pronounced role in individualistic
cultures. We'll strike
blacked out there on the left.
So shame and collectivistic cultures is
actually highly valued and esteemed as
an emotion.
It's also hypercard Nice.
So we talked about this earlier and
we talked about cultural variation and
emotion.
So by hyper cognizant,
this is an emotion that plays a central
feature in the daily lives of people who
are in collectivistic cultures.
It's talked about a lot.
It's the sort of subject of, you can
think of, of newspaper articles, you know,
literary critiques,
Books, um, what have you.
But it's something that's thought about
a lot and as part of everyday language
in a really powerful way.
And as a result,
the experience of shame actually does
lead people to behavioral changes.
They actually are motivated to sort of
try to remedy or fix these group norm
violations.
So a lot of the work that we've talked
about so far has really been in the
context of individualistic cultures.
So I think it's just important to keep
in mind that there's always cultural
variation and this is one way that
culture plays a really powerful role and
actually showing here that
shamed can lead to ultimate good.
Whereas in more individualistic cultures,
as we talked about earlier,
it seems not to sort of
mobilize people to do much,
but they actually sort of retreat and
withdraw and remained stagnant. Um,
so just keep that in mind with all
these emotions, the role of culture.
So what I'm going to do
now is show some data, um,
that's going to directly
compare guilt and shame.
And with the caveat that this is work
that has been done largely in Westernized
cultures where we've tried to understand
the experience primarily of, you know,
us residents in the ways in which guilt
and shame are actually similar and
distinct. So many of us use
these terms interchangeably.
In what ways are we justified doing that?
Are we really referring to the same
thing or are we misusing these words and
should really pull them apart and really
recognize their nuances and differences.
So let's turn now to how
guilt versus shame play out.
So I want to start first with some of
the similarities between guilt and shame.
So here's a list of similarities
between these two emotions.
So broadly speaking,
they're both in the family of self
conscious emotions as we've talked about
earlier.
They're also considered moral emotions
and so far as their response to what you
can see below some sort of wrongdoing,
right,
of judging and act as being
morally wrong or, or incorrect. Um,
and in many ways they have the capacity
to try to help promote prosocial or out
touristic behavior, even though
they're associated with wrongdoing.
We largely see them helping,
as we said earlier,
inhibit aggressive tendencies and
promote more prosocial or cooperative
tendencies.
They're all so similar in so far as they,
we experienced them socially.
So we experience these emotions in the
context of other people and we think a
lot about other people when
we feel guilt or shame. Um,
but as much as these are similarities
in terms of relating ourself to someone
else and these emotions
being socially inherent, um,
the nature of the interpersonal appraisals
or the way we think about our role in
a social sort of context is actually
quite different between guilt and shame.
So for example,
with guilt,
what this is really about
is thinking about, you know,
a specific behavior perceived
by others perhaps is wrong.
And so this is really about,
you know,
guilt as a specific behavior that might
be perceived by others as wrong onto the
self.
Whereas shame by contrast again is part
of this kind of Golo noble sense of self
evaluation that is negative, that
is inherently flawed, that has,
that is wrong or defective in some way
that is then transmitted to other people.
So you feel yourself that you've done
something fundamentally wrong and that
this is something that should, you
know, be seen easily by others.
So what I want to say here is as much as
these emotions are both very social in
nature and they're really about the way
we interact and think of our role in a
social context,
even within these similarities,
we start to see some important
differences emerge. And so with that,
I want to turn to some of the more salient
differences that seem to be apparent
when we really pit guilt
versus shame side by side.
So one of the interesting differences
between shame and guilt is the extent to
which they focus on what's called
local versus global factors.
So let's tell you what I mean here.
So we're looking at guilt and shame
and we see this local versus global
distinction.
So guilt is thought of as
a local focused emotion.
So it's focused on something specific
so you feel bad about some contained
specific behavior.
Um,
whereas shame is more
about global dispositions.
So you're not feeling bad
about one aspect of yourself.
You're feeling bad about yourself very
globally. And very generally, right?
So it's just sort of
diffuse and spreads all out.
Whereas skill is very local and
contained about a specific instance. Um,
so for example, guilt would be, uh,
associated with statements such
as how could I have done that?
Whereas Shane by contrast is
how could I have done that?
And so this plays out to,
whereas with guilt having
these local kind of focus,
the person might think there's something
wrong with what I did in that specific
instance where shame would be
more readily associated with,
there's something wrong with me overall.
So guilt is local shame
has a more global focus.
They also differ in the extent to which
they motivate people to amend or fix the
wrongdoing versus sort of
retreat and hide away from it.
So again, we're going to pit
guilt versus shame side by side.
So we see guilt is associated
with more amending behavior.
So you want to try to correct or
redress the wrongdoing where shame,
we talked about this, you're sort
of, you know, hunter posture over,
you withdraw into a corner,
you want to hide and sort of get out
of the social spotlight altogether as a
result.
Um,
guilt is often associated with this
amending behavior where you feel motivated
to address the problem,
where a shame you really are motivated
to hide from the problem to sort of get
away from it all together.
Yeah.
And so, um, as a result, some people
have talked about guilt as sort of,
you know, facing the music,
right? You, you go and apologize,
you try to undo the wrong
and you try to repair it.
Where shame has also often been talked
about is trying to sort of duck the heat.
So disappear or hide or
escape from whatever situation
made you feel ashamed in
the first place.
So guilt motivates us to amend or
fix what happened that went wrong.
Shame motivates us to hide and
get away from it all together.
Yeah.
And this is a really interesting one
because both of these emotions also have
different relationships.
To empathy.
So empathy is this ability to sort of
get in the mind of others and understand
their emotions,
to kind of connect to the thoughts and
feelings of other people and shame and
guilt are quite different and how
they relate to feelings of empathy.
So if we put them side by side,
we see here that guilt is this
very other oriented emotion, right?
As much as it's self conscious,
it really motivates you to try to connect
to the thoughts and feelings of others.
And by contrast,
shame is very self oriented.
It's these global negative feelings about
oneself and your attention is really
sort of turned inwards in this way.
As a result,
guilt being other oriented helps you
take other people's perspective in a
situation where you've done something
wrong. Whereas shame being self oriented,
you're really sort of
taking your own perspective.
You're sort of caught up in what,
what is your perception of what happened?
And as a result,
guilt is associated with an increased
stability to empathize with other people
and shame is associated with a decreased
ability to empathize with other people.
Also there's the sense in which there's
a defensive versus non defensive
attitude about the wrongdoing and guilt
and shame also differ quite strongly in
this respect.
So guilt has a general defensive response
associated with it where shame has
this more defensive response. And let
me give you an example of what I mean.
So guilt,
having a non defensive response motivates
people to try to rationally discuss
the situation,
to kind of take proactive behavior to
remedy the wrong doing or behavior they
committed.
Whereas shame because it's all about
the self and he's a negative overall
evaluations,
you're more prone to try to blame other
people as almost this of this way to
escape feeling shamed about
yourself. Um, and so for example,
as a result with guilt,
when we think about emotions of anger,
even though you may feel angry,
you know,
when you've done something
that makes you feel guilty,
you'll feel sort of agitated about it,
you're more motivated to try to manage
that anger constructively and proactively.
Whereas shame people are more prone
to experiencing greater anger overall,
then people prone to guilt,
but they also manage their feelings of
anger differently. So they're actually,
when you're prone to shame,
you're more prone to engaging in
aggressive behaviors. So again,
guilt is a more non
defensive way of responding.
Shame is a more defensive
way of responding.
So I want to return now to our example
with tiger woods and ask yourself now,
after you know, you've learned a
bit more about guilt and shame.
Did he really experience guilt
or did he experience shame?
And I won't tell you
what the right answer is,
but I'd be interested to hear what you
think after learning a bit about the
nature of guilt and shame.
And so with that,
I want to conclude with our takeaway
questions and then our expert interview.
So our takeaway questions for today goes,
follows first,
what are the key features again,
and you elicit or the behavior
and the consequence of guilt.
What are the key features, again, elicit
her behavior and consequence of shame.
And as we just talked about at
the end of the lecture today,
what were the key areas of similarities?
The way in which these two motions
showed overlapping features and what were
some of the really profound differences
that really teased apart the ways in
which shame and guilt can actually
be quite a significantly different
subconscious emotions as well.
We'll now turn to our expert interview.
So our expert interview as part of the
broader experts in emotion interview
series today. Um, for our
experts and emotion interview.
We have the honor of speaking
with doctor June Tangney um,
on shame and guilt, the
good, the bad and the ugly.
So Dr Tangney received her phd in
clinical psychology from the University of
California,
Los Angeles and is currently a professor
of psychology at George Mason Mason
University.
She's a fellow of the APA division of
personality and social psychology and the
American psychological society. She's
authored or edited several books on shame,
uh, including and, and as well as
guilt and self conscious emotions.
These books include shame and guilt,
social psychological foundations
of clinical psychology,
the self conscious emotions,
theory and research and the
handbook of self and identity.
Her research has been funded by the end.
Ida and I see HD and SF and
the John Templeton Foundation.
Um,
she's also a very much loved teacher
and recipient of the George Mason
University's teaching excellence award.
So I now turn to our experts and emotion
interview with doctor June Tangney.